les derniers ont plié leurs tentes ce
matin 2000 topher se sont donnés rendez
vous ce week end à yzeures sur creuse
pour une free party en plein champ la
préfecture avait pourtant pris les
devants en prenant 2 1 t2 arrêté
d'interdiction en vain donc jusqu'à 120
gendarmes mais aussi des secours ont dû
être déployés romain des villes étaient
sur place
rejoindre une free party c'est toute une
aventure avec les gendarmes qui bloquent
l'accès aux routes il faut marcher
quatre kilomètres à travers champs
passer une forêt pour accéder au tây de
s'y rendent le lieu de rendez vous sur
la commune 10 heures sur creuse pour ce
groupe de jeunes chauffeurs
c'est une sorte de rituel obligé et plus
joyeux d'accéder à une genre de soirée
où on a traversé une colline une forêt
ou en soit on sait même pas où on va et
ses couleurs fh pas vraiment j'aime bien
sur place les dj se relaie avec leurs
différents styles but mélodique au
hardcore pur et dur
un vent de liberté souffle sur la plaine
lena des deux-sèvres partage le moment
avec sa mère le top 5
c'est les années quatre-vingt six hyper
violent et aplatit clos tout ça
il ya des gens de tout âge tu viens moi
j avec ma mère et c'est super cool ça
veut dire quoi y'a vraiment des gens de
tous les âges pour le coup et puis c'est
intergénérationnel
est monté une fête illégale car mon
déclarait c'est pour beaucoup un acte
politique prendre possession d'un champ
sans rien demander installez les murs du
son c'est créer un espace autogéré
alternatif et hors du système légal de
la même manière que le système le
système d'aujourd'hui nous impose
certaines choses et ben nous on leur
impose un peu
nos soirées et je trouve que c'est un
bon moyen de répondre à la répression à
tout ça
changement d'ambiance au poste de
commandement installé dans la salle des
fêtes 10 heures sur creuse le maire de
la commune des pompiers des gendarmes en
uniforme des forces de l'ordre en civil
vérifie en liaison avec les collègues
sur place que la situation est sous
contrôle il ya évidemment la
coordination de l'ensemble des moyens le
fait de bloquer les accès routiers pour
empêcher qu'un nombre plus important de
manifestants un participant se rendre
sur les lieux et ainsi en faisant
croître l'ampleur de l'événement
augmente les risques susceptibles de se
matérialiser le maire a annoncé qu'il
allait porter plainte pour dégradation
des sentiers communaux mais dans une
fête où par définition personnes les
organisateurs officiels cela ne va pas
être facile de trouver des responsables
voilà justement trois plaintes vont être
déposées celle de la commune donc mais
aussi de l'exploitant agricole et du
propriétaire du terrain enfin sur
twitter ce coup de gueule du patron des
pompiers d'indre et loire ils vont
paturel dénonce le détournement des
moyens de secours de leurs missions
régaliennes pour un événement illégal